this morning on the dish
one woman's return to her roots somali
native hawa hassan grew up here in the
united states
but it was her homeland and reconnection
with her family
that sparked her passion a love of east
african cuisine
to bring the flavors of home here she
started a line of sauces
and just released a cookbook in bibi's
kitchen
i sat down with hassan to learn more
about the book and the journey that
brought her to it
papaya with vanilla sauce this is
chemo which is corn potatoes and green
peas
sauteed cabbage also from kenya sugo
from somalia
this table full of african dishes is
food entrepreneur hawa hassan my dream
was to always
be at the table and then slowly but
surely take over the table
and i mean i'm looking at this table
right now i'm like what is happening
you've taken
the recipes for these dishes are all in
hassan's new cookbook
in bibi's kitchen bibi means grandmother
in swahili
and it is bbs from eight african
countries who provided the recipes found
on hassan's pages
oh my god why did you want to do this
book
i wanted to do this book because i
hadn't seen people like myself reflected
in books in this way
and it's exploration and recipes through
conversation
with these women i really felt like they
were missing from the narrative
and in turn i was missing from the
narrative
hassan was born in somalia at the start
of the civil war in 1991
she fled with her mother and siblings to
a refugee camp in kenya
hassan was just four years old my
brother and i went from being children
to like young adult how do you do that
at four
i mean you just do what your mom says
and so everybody started pulling their
weight
her mother had hoped to move the family
to the u.s
but it was hassan alone who got the
chance to go to seattle
at age seven you had to be terrified no
i was playing my role in the family i
thought
here's an adventure i'll get a feel for
the land and then they'll come which i
didn't think it would take more than a
year for them to get documents to come
and as it turned out blackhawk happened
sponsorship for somali stopped my mother
remarried
and moved to norway where they still
live and you were still in seattle
i was still in seattle by middle school
hassan says
she was assimilating to the states i
joined the basketball team
i joined 4-h i became really what i call
an american teenager eating taco bell
was that right
i didn't know how to even do this you
know i
left all this behind did you miss home
you know i didn't give myself an
opportunity to do a lot of missing
because if i did i would have
cracked but what i later found out was
that i had missed the smell of home
or the hawaj that's in here that's what
i'd really miss
after high school hassan began earning a
living as a model
which exceeded expectations financially
but personally
left her wanting more i knew it was in a
space where i was welcomed you know i
was like oh we already have enough of
you
or she's not black enough she's not
white enough i started to really drown
in
narratives that were placed on me i was
everything
but hal hassan and i just kept
thinking about how do i get back to the
center of who i really am and that's
when i went on a quest to
reunite with my family after 15 years
in 2008 hassan finally visited her mom
and siblings in norway
it was incredible in every sense of the
word i had found a belonging
i had found things i'd longed for you
know in my culture we say paradise is at
the feet of your mom
and so to just be at home with her and
be in the kitchen with her to be on the
floor to wake up in the mornings
together
and the smell you got that smell i got
the ooms and the
houlage and all of that so once you had
sort of a taste of that some people
would think why not stay there
with them but you came back why because
i am incredibly independent
but hassan's mom did get her independent
daughter to think about
what was next how did you land on food
it just went back to how can i tell
stories and how can i change the
conversation about
who people are saying somalis are and
how can i do it through food
she saw space in the food industry with
a lack of african cuisine
this is the vanilla the vanilla sauce
for the lobster
oh my gosh it's a great holiday dish
in 2015 she launched her first venture
baspas the sauce line i just thought
hot sauce you know why not slowly inch
my way
onto the table by introducing people to
flavors of where i'm from
what started in a kitchen in harlem has
grown into nationwide distribution of
baspa sauces with a focus
on direct to consumer sales the advice
that was given to me was to write a
business plan
and so i knew two sauces from somalia
build it for a few years get a proposal
going for in bibi's kitchen
while doing that write a pitch for a
show
all of it has just come to pass adding
diversity hassan
says to an industry still in need of it
oh there's lots of tokenizing i won't be
in a space that doesn't have
people that look like me in it or is not
welcoming to folks like me if i get
inside i always ask for another person
who looks like me to come along and if
there's some pushback from that i know
how to pack up my bags and leave
hassan traces that steadfastness in
herself and her beliefs
to her mom traits also belonging
to the bbs in her cookbook all of them
are really proud
and a little grateful that these stories
are outside of themselves now
where we are as a society right now in
the conversations we're having
about race about inclusion about
changing the system does this fit in in
some way does happen absolutely
when you bring people together over a
plate of food a glass of wine
no conversation is too big or too small
i think that
for the first time in this country the
hard conversations are being had and so
my space in that is to be able to bring
people together put the food on the
table and allow my community to speak to
one another
and there's a saying that that she's
used before she wants to build longer
tables and shorter fences and that sort
of helps to have that conversation with
the food
she her plans are expanding that sauce
line right now and she's working on a
couple other projects but really an
incredible story to get to where she is
now
from where she came i love that she
missed the smell of home yeah right
doesn't that make sense it's all about
those smells
from childhood and we all have always
come back to you yes yeah i was looking
at the food on that table and it took me
back to kenyon tanzania we used to call
those little bites kidogos because they
kidogo and ki swahili means small so it
was just like
nibbling on food and getting a taste of
it all and her point was that that was
just missing from the industry because
it hadn't been brought there the same
with a book like this somebody hadn't
proposed it people didn't know
now it is out there right now it just
adds to the diversity and we'll go out
and buy it
can't wait to try them